so as i mentioned we're starting to get
more details of these deaths that have
occurred in storm eunice uh four people
killed as far as we know three in
england one in ireland as you can see
there skies aisha zahid is in north
london
where a woman died i should tell us more
an absolutely tragic incident there's a
police cordon in place that one of the
officers on the scene has told me he
expects it to remain in place until
potentially tomorrow morning because it
was a significantly large tree that had
fallen onto this car around 4 pm this
afternoon that's when the police were
called out alongside paramedics and also
fire services but unfortunately it was
confirmed on the scene that a woman in
her 30s she'd been a passenger in the
vehicle had lost her life and a man also
in his 30s was taken to hospital though
police say that he doesn't have
life-threatening
injuries now this is this was the first
confirmed death in england but we've
heard of two more a man in his 50s lost
his life as a result of storm units in
merseyside he had been in a vehicle that
was hit the windscreen was hit by debris
and then another man in his twenties
lost his life in hampshire after a van
that he was traveling in was hit by a
tree and then one death also in ireland
a man
being hit by a fallen tree as well so
four deaths so far and several others
injured as a result of storm eunice